let's begin with millions of Americans
facing busy roads and packed airports
this holiday weekend at Seattle's main
Airport TSA wait times were reported to
be at least an hour one traveler said
the lines were quote worse than Disney
World speaking of Disney World more than
a million people are expected to travel
through Orlando's airport this long
weekend up 16 from last year Chris Van
Cleef has been on the move and he's in
Phoenix today Chris good morning how is
it looking
well good morning as Sky Harbor and
airports across the country are waking
up they're getting ready for what we
know will be a very busy day why do we
know that on Friday the TSA screened
more than 2.7 million people that's the
most since November of 2019 so
pre-pandemic and one of the agency's
busiest days ever for the airlines each
and every flight and there have been
tens of thousands of those this weekend
each and every one of them is a game of
beat the clock
on the ramp at Phoenix Sky Harbor
airport time is working against Anthony
fakera and his team you think you and
your team's ready
[Music]
in the next hour they need to unload all
the bags from American flight 474 from
Philly then load up this fully booked
Airbus a321 so flight 1318 to Palm
Springs can get people on their way to
their long weekend on time we prepared
the best we could
especially in the summertime we know
we're going to be like rushing around
and loading bags by the dozens while the
plane is prepped and fueled to fly
40 to 50 people work on turning each of
these planes around and it's something
that American Airlines does more than
200 times a day here at Phoenix Sky
Harbor alone
high above Sky Harbor ground controllers
are scanning the tarmac making sure all
those planes end up at the right place
at the right time once it lands we'll
bring it to the gate make sure that it's
clean catered swept whatever we need to
do to get it out on time again
bubble of America American Airlines
expects to fly 52 million people this
summer on nearly 470 000 flights almost
3 million of those flyers over Memorial
Day weekend since 2021 the airline has
added 17 600 employees staffing issues
at U.S airlines last summer led to a
spike in delays and cancellations
Memorial Day and really the entire
summer season is is is our Super Bowl is
there a pressure that things go better
this year than last year yes we actually
started planning for summer of 23 back
in summer of 22. American Senior vice
president Brady Burns we took a lot of
you know effort and investment and
making sure that we've got the right
people at the right place with the right
tools and we feel really really good
Burkhart Patton will feel really good
once he's on his way to Dallas I'm going
to see family so that's important I want
to get there on time back at gate 823
the door is closed flight 1318 is on its
way to Palm Springs before that
countdown clock could strike zero
es for the most part have been winning
that game of Beat the Clock the weather
has largely cooperated which is good
news but when it doesn't American
Airlines is using new technology it
calls Heat at its Dallas-Fort Worth Mega
Hub to better detect the weather and how
to respond they say it is helping them
respond and recover faster When Storms
get disruptive Tony
all right Chris thank you very much